[Music]
i suggest we
segue to free speech on social media so
this is this is something you track very
closely
and
there are a number of notes out in front
of me you know texas and florida have
passed laws banning the platforms
various platforms from moderating
content
elon is against twitter content
moderation supposedly you know spotify
has
taken down some backlist from joe rogan
and there are a lot of open questions
related to this and i think a lot of
perhaps
undefined terms and other issues that we
can explore so where would where would
you like to begin with free speech on
social media
well let me begin personally just with
the disclosure which is that
having helped what was then facebook
make its oversight board i still advise
meta on free speech issues and i also
sometimes advise other social media
companies like tick tock
and so i'm not i'm not going to claim to
be wholly objective about this that said
i
try very hard and i think this is why
i'm of use when i do advise
to not tell anybody what they want to
hear
so what i'm going to say is just me
talking
and it's what i
what i actually believe
so i guess what i think is
most fascinating
is that we're at a
really interesting inflection point
about free speech and social media
associated with elon musk's
proposed
twitter takeover and you and i have been
both very fascinated to watch and see
whether that would actually happen in
the end and maybe you want to share your
grand theory about it tim but in any
case what's fascinating about it is that
in
saying he's going to take take over
twitter and take it private musk has not
said
i'm doing this because
i think this is a great business
and i'm really good at business
and i can make a company run well and i
think there's a lot of money to be made
in it nor has he said
you know i think it'd be really cool to
do x which is one of the things he does
say usually i mean that's sort of the
spacex theory it would be really cool to
do x and i can make money at it
instead he expressed for i think the
first time at least in his public
business career
a kind of
free speech related values-based view he
basically said i don't think it's good
that
twitter limits people's free speech
through content moderation and i want to
change that
so that's a pretty substantial reason to
spend 40 billion dollars even if you had
at the time
you know maybe three or four times that
i'm not sure he still does but even if
he had at the time through four times
that that's a pretty fascinating
motivation it's a really different kind
of motivation and it's not only unusual
for him it's unusual for anybody
you know we we might expect you know
jeff bezos to buy the washington post
but that did not cost any 40 billion
dollars for him to buy you know or to
sustain you know that's a relatively
small purchase from the standpoint of
someone you know with a with a ton of
money so
the moment that we're in is a moment
where
the idea that content moderation is a
problem for free speech is getting a lot
of air time
and where simultaneously on the other
side
you've got the idea that the deep
platforming of donald trump from
effectively all of the major social
media outlets at the time
was something that remains supported
by many many liberals in the political
spectrum
notwithstanding that it's hard to
imagine a greater violation of the
principle of free speech
than that the guy who was present in the
united states then and remains you know
the most popular politician on the
republican side
can't speak
through these platforms especially given
that the guy donald trump made his
reputation to some significant degree
using twitter
so we've got sort of the two extreme
positions
arrayed here
and what we don't have is a lot of
clarity about the terms
on which this fight should be played out
so i can say more about that by the way
if you want i was just pausing so i
don't go on for too long yeah please say
more and i would also just love to know
if we're dealing with
a wide spectrum
of
definitions for
free speech
or if it's free speech in quotation
marks with
other motives
at play you don't have to speak to that
right now but i would like to explore
that because totally that's exactly
where i was going to go great let's go
there because i think i like many people
are like well wait a second like what
this person is calling free speech
is not i think what one would find the
perhaps legal or constitutional
definition to be and then what this
person is calling free speech is really
driven by this motivated reasoning
around what they want or some financial
outcome or who knows what so i'd love
you to expand on that
your insight tim is actually i think the
single most important starting point for
figuring out what's going on in this
debate right now and it's that we can't
define what free speech is unless we dig
down a little bit underneath the slogan
so free speech has two different
meanings basically
one meaning is the ordinary meaning of
the term
which means something like i get to say
what i want
to whom i want when i want to say it
and that would include my saying it on
social media and if i'm d platform from
social media or if my post is taken away
because it violates
the terms of service or community
standards of a particular
social media platform then under that
ordinary meaning of free speech my free
speech has been limited i can't i can't
talk in the place in a way that i want
to talk
then there's what you might call the
lawyer's definition of free speech or
the constitutional definition of free
speech and that's really narrow
what that says is that under the first
amendment to the us constitution
the government can't stop me from
speaking
but only the government
a private party can stop me from
speaking
so the example i i always use with my
con law students though they may be
irritated me for doing this is i point
out that if you teach constitutionalize
your day job like i do your kids at a
very early age tell you when they you
tell them to be quiet that they have
free speech rights
so my son i don't know how old he was
when he said that but very very young
you know maybe five or something
and i explained to him then and you know
for a couple of years afterwards that he
actually didn't have free speech rights
visa be me he only had free speech
rights relative to the government but i
could tell him to shut up and i could
give him consequences if he didn't you
know close this now they're not say or
do a particular thing and he didn't like
that very much but i think for my
students it's a good way to remember the
constitutional definition it's the
reason you can tell someone to shut up
without violating the constitution and
similarly under that constitutional
definition
so far at least and i'm gonna go there
in a moment but so far at least
if a social media platform which is a
private company
which has its own constitutional rights
tells one of its users you can't say
that or we're kicking you off the
platform
it the social media platform has a
constitutional free speech right
to say we don't want to carry your
speech
and you the user have zero
constitutional rights
vis-a-vis the social media platform
so notice right away that that's a
completely different definition of free
speech and it's one that's just focused
on the government
what's fascinating what's really
fascinating is that that second
constitutional norm is under some
pressure
because there are now some supreme court
justices
at least two probably three
who have been telegraphing in short
opinions not in full supreme court
opinions but in short
opinions
that they think
that the idea of constitutional free
speech should be reinterpreted
so that
the social media companies
can't regulate all of the speech on
their platforms and claim the protection
of the first amendment when they do so
and those justices are conservative
justices have a really interesting
set of arguments
arguments that four or five years ago
liberals kind of liked but then liberals
gave up on them but now conservatives
like them
and those arguments basically say
something like this
a ton of our conversation is happening
on social media
maybe we should analogize social media
companies to
a common carrier like a telephone
company a telephone wire company which
can't pick and choose who's allowed to
get a telephone and who isn't going to
like to get a telephone based on what
they're going to say over their
telephone
or maybe they should be thought of as
public accommodations
sort of like
a chain of hotels which can't say we're
not letting you stay in our hotel
because we don't like you
that would be discrimination and it
would be unlawful and so those justices
are saying we should reconceptualize the
social media platforms is more like one
of those two things
either like a common carrier or like a
public accommodation and we should allow
the government
to pass laws that say they can't
discriminate on the basis of viewpoint
and the state of texas because they like
to be out ahead that was a joke
the state of texas passed such a law
they have in fact passed such a law
they passed the laws saying it wasn't a
very funny joke they passed a law saying
that social media companies with more
than a certain number of users i think
was 50 million users or something like
that so the big social media companies
cannot take down any content based on
the viewpoint expressed by the social
media company
and of course the social media platforms
and others immediately went to court to
get that law blocked
and the first court said okay we're
going to block the law then the court of
appeals said we're reinstating the law
and then the supreme court by a very
close vote by a five to four vote said
the law is not going to go into
operation
while the lower courts figure out if
it's constitutional or not so that legal
court case is ongoing and it's going to
be really really really
important because it goes to this core
question of whether those two different
definitions of free speech should remain
pulls apart two different definitions or
whether they should come together
and become a single definition of what
counts as free speech
you